hey guys today i'm doing a photo shoot
for angel jackets and i decided to show
you how to style leather jackets for men
[Music]
all right now the first little jacket
i'm using is the brown bomber jacket
with a removable hood from angel jackets
it'll cost you just under 200 but it's a
classic real leather jacket and for this
casual look i'm wearing these ripped
light blue jeans from tsar
white sneakers from oliver cabell
then a white crew neck tee from zara
and to make the look even better these
accessories
the paloma bourbon sunglasses from
christopher cluess
and finally my favorite classy watch
from hugo boss both of them match the
color of the jacket now just remember i
will add all the product links with
their discount codes for you in the
video description below if you want to
check it out
[Music]
the rugged look so for this look i'm
wearing the brown bomber jacket again
but without the removable hood
and with it the dark blue jeans from
zara
these rugged brown boots from aldo
the cocky crew neck shirt from zara
and finally the silver anchor bracelet
in brown from zaroto
[Music]
now for the smart look i chose my new
favorite jacket which is the johnson
dark brown quilted motorcycle jacket
from angel jacks
it works great with these brown double
monk strap shoes from ace marks
[Music]
with the white trousers from zara
then i have my brown boss watch on with
this silver lion bangle from zarata
[Music]
and finally this polo sweater from
superbalist
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
now let's move over to a black colored
jacket because most guys either wear
brown or black leather jackets for this
casual look i'm wearing the black dodge
leather jacket from angel jackets now
this is a cool jacket it lets you think
of van diesel in the fast interference
anyway for the rest of the outfit i got
the white crew neck shirt from zara
the silver anchor bracelet in black to
fit with the color of the jacket
and then finally the black ripped jeans
from zara
with the black sneakers from oliver
cabell
do you see how the black and white
colors work together in this casual
streetwear outfit it looks good doesn't
it
[Music]
the rugged look the first thing i
changed into to have a rugged look is of
course the rugged boots from tissoni
which works great with the rugged jeans
from zara then i have the screw neck
shirt from zara and to complete the look
with accessories the silver lion stack
bracelets with the silver line ring from
zarata
[Music]
now the smart look now of this outfit
i'm still using the same black deutsch
leather jacket from angel jackets
with the two-tone silver bangle from
zarata
[Music]
to make it look great i had to go with
my black antique chelsea boots from ace
marks
and i'm also wearing the cream crew neck
shirt from zara
[Music]
for accessories i'm wearing the black
silver academy black croc watch from
zarato
[Music]
and these black aviator sunglasses
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now if you want to get a good leather
jacket it is important to buy a real
leather jacket quality is always better
than quantity because it will look
better on you and it'll last a lot
longer as well
now always remember life is sure so
don't waste yours i'll see you guys in
the next video cheers